[Music]
with technology being what it is today
artificial intelligence is no longer
something in the distant future or just
in science fiction movies
the potential for ai to assist us in our
day-to-day tasks has become very real
but with that comes the fear that they
can rise up to become
super intelligent and autonomous beings
and
act against us and it wouldn't exactly
be hard for them
they've got the numbers we are entirely
dependent on them in our daily lives
and they are not hindered by emotions
which means they lack
empathy if that isn't enough reason to
be afraid of them
buckle in because we're about to give
you a few more
welcome back to our channel if you
haven't already make sure you hit the
subscribe button
and ring that bell so you're notified
every time we upload a new video
we're using thinking machines every day
from the google search algorithm to
apple's siri
to amazon's alexa ai has been embedded
into our lives
and with machines constantly learning
from themselves and programmers creating
more powerful ones
some of the most intelligent people in
the world are worried
as they should be but not for the
reasons you might
think when we say ai could be dangerous
you're probably picturing something like
terminator
or irobot or age of ultron but them
getting mad at us is quite honestly the
least of our worries
besides anger revenge frustration these
are all human emotions
and as we said before computers aren't
hindered by these emotions
so what exactly should we fear elon musk
once tweeted that artificial
intelligence is
quote more dangerous than nukes this
tweet is in reference to a book by nick
bostrom called
super intelligence and it talks about
something called the control problem
it goes something like this let's say
you assign a task to an ai
it could be anything but the book uses
the example of making paper clips
because it's an ai you don't need to
provide step-by-step instructions
you just tell it the desired outcome in
this case it's to make as many paper
clips as possible with the resources
available but for the ai
available resources aren't limited to
what's been explicitly provided
technically it could turn the entire
planet into paper clips
what bostrom writes in his book is the
ai will quickly realize that it would be
much better if there were no humans
because humans might decide to switch it
off
because if humans do so there would be
fewer paper clips
also human bodies contain a lot of atoms
that could be made into paper clips
the future that the ai would be trying
to gear towards would be one
in which there were a lot of paper clips
but no humans
now this isn't the most probable outcome
but it works as an excellent example to
explain the problem
elon musk recognizes this and like many
people in tech he has funded the
research to solve this problem
he pledges one billion dollars to open
ai so they can work on discovering
and enacting the path to safe artificial
intelligence
but there are more reasons to fear the
rise of ai than the control problem
there are some real issues around ai
that are already affecting our
day-to-day lives
for one ai is a job killer they can
and already have caused mass
unemployment and it was primarily
blue-collar workers in manufacturing and
delivery jobs that took
the hit it won't be long before
white-collar service-oriented jobs are
affected too
as they become more intelligent a
trained workforce will no longer be
required the fact is
ai and machines can manage 80 percent of
any of these jobs
the unemployment wave is approaching
fast 47 to 81
of american jobs will be under threat
within 20 years
while 137 million jobs will be lost in
southeast asia
but if kicking back and getting to relax
while the robots handle all the chores
sounds like a dream
there are still more problems another
common fear where ai is concerned is
governments using them to cause harm
it's no surprise that right now
countries are pouring crazy amounts of
money into developing ai systems to help
military advancement and manipulate the
news as they see
fit ai could soon be used to weaponize
nations when you first think about it it
doesn't seem like such a bad idea to use
machines for war
so human lives can be saved but there's
more to it than that
what if the machines malfunction what
about the countries that don't have the
necessary tech resources to build such
systems and how would civilians protect
themselves in 2015
swedish american physicist max tegmark
expressed his concern about autonomous
weapons in an open letter
it asked governments to avoid building
potentially dangerous ai
because in its essence ai was meant to
be beneficial for the human race
and not cause destruction seventeen
thousand individuals
including stephen hawking signed that
letter but how effective would that
letter be
only time will tell if they're working
on such technologies the day isn't far
when governments use ai systems in ways
that will make us afraid for the way
they're used for surveillance
law enforcement and warfare and since ai
technologies tend to learn from their
creators
if the creator's intentions are bad well
bad things
will happen and this isn't limited to
warfare and excessive surveillance
if ai learns from its creator we could
have many more problems that affect our
day-to-day lives
for example our artificially intelligent
algorithms are informed by years of
prejudice and historical biases
because of automated ad placements women
are statistically less likely to see ads
for high-paying jobs than men
the correctional offender management
profiling for alternative sanctions or
compass since that's quite a mouthful
predicts black defendants will be more
likely to reoffend
than white defendants even if that isn't
true and these predictions aren't
expected to get better
but one thing we don't have to be afraid
of is robots killing us all
that is unless you are directly involved
with the development of ai
or you direct policy or resources that
can influence the development of ai
and if the concern is that the developer
will create an ai that wants to wipe out
the population
well there's not much you can do about
it you might as well worry about the
earth getting hit by an asteroid
so why aren't these possibilities ever
explored in movies as a warning of
what's to come
well simply because job killing and
systemic inequalities aren't as visually
thrilling as say
captain america drop kicking a drone but
the reality is that it's here
right now and unlike the control problem
we can actually do something about it
right now
we could look at policy responses like
minimum basic
income or shifting taxation systems to
favor labor over capital
we could see how humans add unique value
to our businesses in a way robots never
could
most importantly we can demand
transparency in algorithmic decision
making
and transform our education system to
prepare kids for a lifetime of
continuous learning and adaptation we
are co-creating our futures every minute
we live on this planet
so we can either make conscious choices
about it or we can let it happen to us
because if not ai might either decide
that the world is simply a better place
without us
and will work to eradicate us in order
to create a utopian world
or they will learn the worst of our
ideologies and use it against us
and the scary dystopian future that we
see in movies
will become a reality but if we
consciously work on creating a better
future we can hope for robots like c-3po
or jarvis which are highly intelligent
robots but still
controllable by humans what do you think
let us know in the comments below
if you enjoyed the video make sure you
hit the like button and check out more
on the simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time